any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
breaking news today has been announced
from
uh from harvard university courtesy of
none other than past guest and frequent
guest frequent friend of the show
professor avi loeb uh we're gonna get
into everything that's happened since
the last
time he was on the podcast when his
wonderful book came out extraterrestrial
but today he is joining us to make a
special announcement and i actually have
a connection to avi about special
announcements and it has to do with an
announcement
he helped to make in 2014 on
march 17th i'll remember the day for the
rest of my life
and it was about 400 or so years
after uh 450 years or so after galileo
galilei
uh uh his birth and that announcement
was about a refracting telescope
uh named bicep2 and uh avi was a big
part of that announcement but today he's
making an announcement
also connected to galileo galilei and uh
i don't know much about it but it is so
exciting to hear the announcement that
was just made
live from the uh from cfa and elsewhere
avi
first of all how are you doing my friend
and what is this big announcement what
does it have to do with the maestro my
hero
galileo galilei thank you brian it's
great to be with you
um and the reason we chose the name
galileo for this project
is because it has a potential of
revolutionizing
our world view i'm not saying we will
definitely discover something as
fundamental as galileo discovered which
was basically the case that we might not
be at the center of the universe
prior to him it was very flattering to
the ego of
a lot of people to believe that we are
at the center and
it started with aristotle and many other
people and
then galileo argued otherwise and of
course the response was quite uh
negative and if he was living today he
would have been cancelled on social
media
but instead the philosophers at the time
refused to look through his telescope
they basically argued that they know the
answer
uh without that and um put him in house
arrest
and so that he would not communicate his
message
to a lot of people and what that
accomplished
is that their ignorance was maintained
for a while
but the earth continued to move around
the sun and the
the lesson we learned from that is that
looking
through new telescopes is a good idea
rather than closing the curtains on our
windows and saying
you know the answer so we might say we
are the smartest
in the universe there is no smarter kid
on our cosmic block
and close off the windows but that
doesn't remove
any smarter kid from our neighborhood it
only
maintains our ignorance and in much the
same spirit
what this project the galileo project is
proposing is
to open the curtains on our windows and
look out
and search for evidence now it might
well be
that we are the smartest kid on the
block there is nobody
else as a lot of my colleagues argue uh
and of course that would be reassuring
it will give
it will enhance our self-esteem but on
the other hand
the answer may be different and science
is based on evidence i should remind
i was asked in a forum a few weeks ago
how do i define an intelligent culture
and my definition was it's a
civilization
that follows the guiding principles of
science namely
cooperation and sharing of
evidence-based
knowledge and there are two components
to it one is cooperation
sharing which we don't practice very
often along
human history if you see uh the most
common
uh phenomenon that you find is
people trying to feel superior relative
to each other fighting each other
not cooperating and the second part of
this
is evidence-based knowledge so again
people tend to believe that they know
the answer in advance without the
evidence
they prefer to stay in their comfort
zone and what this project
advocates is searching for evidence and
the reason that this project was
announced
is because there were two interesting
events over the past four years or so
first
in october 2017 there was the first
object discovered from outside the solar
system
in the vicinity of earth it was given
the name omua mua which means a scout in
the hawaiian language because the
telescope discovered it
was in a y and that's what my book was
about
this object didn't look like a comet or
an asteroid
nothing like we have seen before and
even the scientists that tried to
explain it as a natural object
had to invoke something that we've never
seen before
like a hydrogen iceberg nitrogen iceberg
or a douse cloud of dust particles
but this was the first one that we found
and clearly
it's not like the rocks that we often
find in the solar system so
it could be of artificial origin and
then
the pentagon sent a report to congress
admitting that there are some objects in
the sky that may be real
but we don't know the nature of and you
know that's an
amazing admission by the government
that they're not doing their job because
their job the intelligence agencies are
supposed
to figure out what flies in the sky
right it's a matter of national security
so here they come out not only admitting
that
they see things uh that they haven't
yet uh fully explored but but in
fact they see things that they cannot
explain and
that's when this subject should move
away from the talking points of
politicians national security advisors
or military personnel to the realm of
science
because it would never go to a plumber
and ask the plumber to bake you a cake
right so for the same reason you
wouldn't ask politicians or
military personnel to explain what they
see in the sky
that's the profession of astronomers and
that's the rationale behind this uh
project the galileo project looking at
the sky and figuring out the nature of
unidentified aerial phenomena or
uh um like objects these are objects
near earth
that could potentially be equipment sent
by another civilization but if it ends
up being something else
at least we explained it and right now
you know there is a dense fog
that prevents us from realizing what
these objects are
so i don't know if i told you this last
time but um when i was preparing for a
video that i made about the dialogue and
two chief world systems
i first consulted amazon.com where your
book extraterrestrial was number one
bestseller
and i couldn't find to my consternation
the audiobook version of any of
galileo's books
so i'm pretty industrious and galileo's
my hero and i said well someone's got to
do this for the old man
and make an audio book get with the 21st
century
and i couldn't figure out how to do it
and long story short i figured out a way
to do it but i said i can't do it alone
i have to reach out to my colleagues to
my friends i reached out to carlo
rivelli
who rivals you uh for book sales and uh
carlo's an italian uh physicist of
course of immense renown and wonderful
writer
and he and i along with my good friend
lucio pichurillo is another italian
physicist
along with jim gates frank wilcheck and
many other but we are reading those
three voices
for the first time in human history and
avi i have to tell you i get the chills
when i read passages
like this that really and should inspire
all the world to take what you're doing
so seriously
this is galileo one of the best writers
not science writers writers in human
history
he said this avi i want to get your
reaction happy art
he's talking about theorists and other
philosophers of the of the uh
ptolemaic or peripatetic school as they
used to call them
he said happy are these people and much
to be envied for this
for if a knowledge of everything is
naturally desired and if being informed
is the same thing as taking
credit for being informed then they
enjoy a very great knowledge
they can persuade themselves that they
know and understand everything
in complete defiance of those who
recognize their own ignorance
of what they do not know these people
perceiving that they know only the
tiniest portion of what's knowable
exhaust themselves in working and
studying and mortify themselves
with as avi just said experiments and
observations this is exactly what you're
doing you're saying
let the observation be the in the judge
let that be the stamp of truth the sign
of nature is truth so i want to ask you
this this project it sounds very
panoptical it sounds like it is
encompassing techno signatures and
biosignage it could do uh
it can slice it can dice where is the
main focus going to be or is that the
idea
to bring together observers
experimentalists theorists
phenomenologists and to get them in a
room and not
debate like the pissing contest who's
right you know i'm better i'm smarter
than you but to do it for the love of
science is that the ultimate goal of the
galileo project
well actually it relates very closely to
the
what you've just read because um there
was
an article in nature astronomy
and not so long ago just a few weeks ago
by a philosopher
making arguments why omuamua is not
likely to be a technological relic
and i look at it and i say you know we
should have learned the lesson that it's
not a matter of philosophy
in fact there is a very simple way to
settle the issue
and that is to take a high resolution
image
of an object like omoammua or of
uap unidentified aerial phenomena just
get a megapixel image
and you will be able to read off the
label that says
made on planet x distinguish it from a
label saying
made in country y and that's all
it's not a philosophical argument they
say a picture is worth a thousand words
in my case a picture is worth 66 000
words
that's right number of words in my book
so i wouldn't need to say anything
if we had a megapixel image of a muammua
and guess what uh i just wrote a
scientific american essay about it
if you were to have an object the size
of a person
at a distance of a mile then with a one
meter
diameter telescope you could
resolve a millimeter feature
on that object so uh you can get a
megapixel image and
uh see a feature the size of the head of
a pin
on the surface of this object and that's
all i want
it's a very simple thing so i went
online and i checked
you know uh what is the cost of a
meter size telescope and i got to a
website that has it
and it just says add to the bag
if you want to buy it and it's half a
million dollars yeah now there must be
people that are willing
to add that telescope to their bag and
pay half a million dollars for them it
must be
you know just peanuts yeah
my point is simple with enough money you
can do it
so now i realized that shortly after
the pentagon report was released
and then the miracle happened which is
two weeks ago
three people or a few people approached
me and said
here is the money you can do with it
whatever you want
now you must understand this is very
rare in academia
you know i've been department chair for
nine years i've been in academia for
several decades
i've never seen something like that so
what happened to me was one day i get an
email from the administrator of the
astronomy department at harvard
saying you have a new account
with new research funds and i say to her
what do you mean i have a new account
could you please let me know who gave me
that money so i can thank that person
and she says i don't you know i'm not
sure first born daughter is missing
right she they took your first
so i said look this is in the military
request
i'm just asking please inform me of the
email address of the person that gave me
this money so i can thank that person
i mean i don't understand why that
should be so complicated
you know it's an and and then eventually
after a day i got that the information
and
and then i get another message saying um
i want to introduce to you uh this multi
billionaire that they wanted to ask you
questions about your book
and i said fine i'll be glad to meet
with him if he comes to my
the porch of my house and then he came a
few days later
and he also decided to help
and and so within a
period of two weeks without doing any
fundraising on my
part i had 1.755
million dollars okay and then i said to
myself okay
well that's a good sum of money with
that i can actually
have a project and then i started
recruiting
uh colleagues uh starting with ed turner
at princeton and
others and we ended up with an excellent
team of exceptional instrumentalists and
mainly astronomers uh and we
have already had a lot of discussions
and we're planning
first thing which instruments we want to
use you know what size telescopes
uh and then of course they will be
connected to cameras
which will fit the data into computer
systems that
will filter out because there will be a
huge flood of data and you can't
keep all the data and then you have to
track objects of interest so
artificial intelligence will play an
important role in this
yeah and of course you know one of the
surreptitious reasons i wanted to get
galileo's words is because with the
rise and advent of artificial
intelligence and programs like gpt-3
it's now possible to take documents of
historical note and put them into gpt3
and query it so my goal and i talked
about this with carlow yesterday
is to create uh galilei i o
uh in other words artificial galileo
where we can feed in
and teach him heisenberg's uncertainty
relations and see
if he can get uh you know some some kind
of uh insight into it that we might be
missing
because you know i think we tend to
lionize and venerate individuals
uh but we do so at the time you know we
make fine men into a hero
and people you know worship these great
uh these great people
from uh you know einstein carl sagan
marie curie is here
but you know i always find that this
notion avi and i think i want to talk to
you about this now
you got a lot of backlash for your book
which i thought was undeserved and
unfair and i want to get into
some of the controversy uh so to speak
but one thing that marie curie
told me she didn't tell me but uh her
fame is famous for she said
be more interested in ideas than people
in other words don't ask what's the
motive of avi loeb or brian keating
doing what they're doing uh and yet
science is made of people
and like you said scientists are curious
and and
and scientists are are inquisitive and
imaginative all these wonderful
qualities
that are unique to science in some ways
but not only to scientists they also are
found in children
and just like children children are
wonderfully curious and
inquisitive and they don't play well
with others and they're jealous and they
don't share
and they want credit and how do you
balance this how do you balance the
first of all talk about the some of the
the the vitriol that you received
and and and and put it in context how
much of it was pure jealousy
how much of it was legitimate because
you know this and you said i put the
data out for all the c
right so some of it is legitimate so
talk about that how do you balance
the the trolls from the legitimate
critics of which there are a few
oh definitely i mean i'm very much in
favor of those scientists that paid
attention to the anomalies of
one try to explain them as a natural
object
and in fact i think that's great because
the objects they
uh suggested were never seen before
we've never seen a hydrogen iceberg a
nitrogen iceberg or
a dust cloud and
therefore it should motivate us to take
data
and of course if we see any of them it
means that there are nurseries of these
objects
that we've never imagined before because
they're very different from the solar
system we've never seen such objects in
the solar system so
and they must be very common so to me
that's the way that we do science right
if we know that there is dark matter
out there various people suggest
different options for what the nature of
dark matter
is and you put those options on the
table and you design
experiments that will try to sort them
out and if you think it's weekly
interacting massive particles which was
the dominant view when i started
in astrophysics back in the 1980s that's
fine and then you invest hundreds of
millions of dollars searching for
weekly interacting massive party you
don't find it okay we didn't find it
but it's part of the scientific inquiry
and the same thing should be done
with or more and more like objects there
are several possible interpretations
all of them invoke something that is new
and we learn
in the process the worst that we can do
is say business as usual
let's ignore the anomalies like one of
my colleagues said
when we left the room of a seminar about
omumu he said
so weird i wish it never existed
and that's the wrong approach because
you should be excited about the
opportunity to learn something new
yes and i should say uh i had a thousand
interviews over the past six months yeah
and
it was you know i mean i i was only 10
of them that's amazing
no the reason i bring this up is the
waters was very turbulent like every day
i would
wake up at 5 00 a.m jog for half an hour
in the company of birds rabbits
ducks and wild turkeys and a single fox
that i i saw
and then then i come home and eight
starting at eight a.m until seven pm i
would have back-to-back interviews which
was
only possible during the pandemic yes so
it was a very
demanding period of time and on top of
that i had to cope with all the
very harsh criticism from people that
don't attend to the anomaly so i'm
completely at peace
with those that try to explain it as a
natural object now
one thing i wanted an anecdote that i
wanted to bring up is
um an orthodox jewish magazine in new
york city in brooklyn
uh called amii meaning for an hour
and then put uh a cover story about my
book
in their magazine the weekly magazine
and uh
when a colleague of mine at harvard
stephen greenblatt who
you know is a shakespearean
scholar uh when he saw it
he said well it looks like the orthodox
are more open-minded than some of your
colleagues
we'll put a link to that uh of course in
the show notes below that that article
uh you know not too many people get you
know front front page or
front cover of ami magazine and also
publish
publish in astrophysical journal uh avi
but uh i do want to make the
the point i have seen this as well and
get your reaction to it
but when you think about how you know
many people are excited about
ufos and unexplained aerial phenomena i
saw a study before the pentagon report
came out
and it said something like you know 30
to 60 of american public wants the
pentagon to spend more money on it
and i was just thinking you know just
being uh being mischievous as i am
you know imagine if it was like god like
searching for god like evidence for god
or whatever
uh but you know i don't think so many
people would be so interested in
spending money on it so there's a thing
that used to be non-partisan right
supportive science
uh you know sometimes uh supportive of
you know mom and apple pie so to speak
that was like everything could be
support but now as people are so
entrenched and
and of course and i had your your you
know a fellow author michio kaku on the
show this summer the spring
and i asked him i said michio you know
like string theory's been around for a
long time
and yet we've had wonderful new results
g minus two l h c
b snow lab plus all these wonderful
experiments hubble tension
how come i don't see like the strength
theorists predicting these things in
advance they always say yes you can go
back you can get it you can
find it in there and i'm like you can
find things in the bible codes too
but anyway uh but but nevertheless i
said mitchell how come we can't like by
what
criterion why but rubric shall we judge
when to stop a project be it the
scientific method that is as it's
applied to string theory
to cosmology inflationary gravitational
wave
searches and your colleague at harvard
peter galinson wrote a wonderful book
how experiments end
but i'm really interested in why
experiments should end in other words
what is the criterium what is the rubric
avi when should we stop searching from
for stop trying to determine what it is
because i think
we need to know what the what the what
the terms are we can't just say
we'll search forever as michio said i
would fund searches for string theory
and searches for alternatives with equal
amounts well that's not really an answer
you know as a yiddish say if you stand
in the middle of the road you get hit by
traffic on both sides
so i want to ask you when should we stop
searching as just a paradigm no i don't
mean specifically um but when would we
stop searching
for its origin what would bring us to
that conclusion right
it's very simple i mean we just started
of course
studying interstellar objects like umua
it was the first one and we saw another
one
called borisov but the point is with the
vera rubin observatory we are likely to
find many more and
um as we find more you know we can for
example
identify an object on its approach to us
a year in advance
and then send the spacecraft we equipped
the camera that will take a close-up
photograph
just like osiris-rex took a photograph
of the asteroid bennu
and actually landed on it and picked up
a sample and
that it will deliver to earth in 2023
and so just imagine
uh us taking a close-up photograph
seeing that it's an artificial piece of
equipment just like a plastic bottle on
the beach
yeah in the landing on it and then
importing the technology
to earth so how many entrepreneurs in
silicon valley would change their plans
as a result of learning a new technology
that can be used to make more money
and it will revise our view about our
place in the universe
uh about our relations with each other
because suddenly
if we recognize a smarter kid next to us
you know all the differences between us
do not make much
uh are not significant you know and so
it will change
international relations it will change
the way people view
uh our place in the universe our
aspirations for space
our theological and philosophical
beliefs it would have a huge impact
you know very different from the dark
matter the document is an action and not
a weekly interactive massive particle it
won't change your daily life in any way
so my point is how can we ignore this
question
when we have the capacity to examine it
scientifically
and that's pretty much the agenda behind
the galileo project and uh what i want
to do is bring this subject
to the mainstream end of science and i
should say
um you know when the pentagon report
came out
bill nelson the head of nasa appeared on
cnn
and said now scientists should look into
those
uap and figure out their nature
so i tried to contact people
under him without much success
i said here i am to serve
and help you make your boss
happy i didn't receive much uh
feedback from that and you know part of
it
is that uh federal agencies rely
on committees uh composed of mainstream
scientists
that are not taking risks are not are
not willing to
um potentially
be proven wrong so so obviously you know
the tendency is to preserve your image
and not
to to become a controversial to discuss
subjects that are
of interest to the public that might not
lead
to what you're expecting but if you look
at the dark matter search
you know that's also a search in the
dark so why should the search for the
nature of those
weird objects be anything different
than any other you know search we do in
the context of
astronomy or science more generally uh i
think it should
it belongs to exactly the same uh
approach and and and in fact uh it's of
great interest to the public and
as demonstrated by the fact that i got
funded uh without doing any fundraising
it means that
there is an opportunity here to fund
science and
guess what that i get you a huge number
of emails from people that are
interested in contributing
to the project and uh scientifically you
know just being part of it
and so what that means is that there
will be many more kids drawn into
science if you were to allow for this
subject to be discussed
so how is it possible that
the scientists not only ridicule any
discussion about it
so they are basically declining the
possibility of getting more funds
and blocking
the acceptance of this subject from
being discussed in a way that
young people are reluctant to engage in
it because they worry about their job
prospects about the way they would be
looked at and so forth
yeah well just to be pushed back
respectfully as i always do
to say that you know when i when i've
had a lot of conversations online with
folks about this problem and this issue
and
so forth uh i i have two different uh
issues
that i have to confront one is that i
often have to teach people about the
scientific method
in other words people will say to me
well here's this video
and i don't care about this guy mick
west uh who debunked it
uh but you know or the seti institute
seth shostak
or jill tarter we'll get to later um but
uh because
they're self-interested you know they
want to find you know
they want to find out if the object is
you know is a radio signal their self
that's their money so as upton sinclair
said it's hard to convince a man or a
woman
of something uh to believe in something
when their job depends on them not
knowing something
and and then so they're basically
impugning that and then and then that
this
other type of person that i get is
people that say give me the data like
i need the data and i say like and avi
i've never said this to you but i want
to get your impression if i'm being
foolish
you look at the hubble deep field it's
beautiful you you've written
one of my recent scientific american
articles that is about to appear
and the point is you know i was someone
asked me about
uap in the context of whether omuamua's
data
is in a way similar to an unidentified
object and i said no it's a completely
different nature because
you know almost data was collected by
telescopes over which we have full
control in the standard scientific way
and the most of the uap reports
or what used to be called ufos uh most
of them
uh were obtained by uh amateurs by
for example even the best reports were
obtained by cameras that were jittery
in a fighter jet and right that's not an
environment where you can reproduce the
trajectory of the fighter jet
and also eyewitness testimonies you know
are subject to
a lot of uncertainties to do with you
know human psychology because
people can have illusion hallucinations
they can fill in the noise yeah
right or or actually people tend to
ignore facts when
they do not for example
flatter their ego or when they
contradict their notions
so you in science you rely on
instruments
collecting quantitative data and the
instruments
have to be under full control that's the
way scientific experiments
so the galileo project is exactly after
that
installing telescopes in various
geographical locations
in the standard way that astronomy is
done except you're not looking at a very
distant
object far away that is barely moving on
the sky you're looking on something that
moves
close to you uh much more on the sky and
so
the search method is different that the
software that will be used to look for
interesting objects
uh is quite different because you know
in astronomy if something flies
above your head and moves quickly then
you just ignore it
uh here we will focus on such things
and when we talk about you know how uh
soon after kind of this this
interest came up of course it's not
really soon as you point out in your
scientific american article earlier this
month
you know people have worried about these
things if they're trojan horses if
they're
you know humanoid and so forth but the
other bias that i think is hard to
overcome is is whether or not
uh the scientists would be not the most
interested people that there are
in this endeavor in other words if you
and i could shortcut and tell go down
the hall
and you could tell cameron vapha past
guest on the show that you know he
should switch into you know
into some other field uh which he'd be
very successful at no matter what he
does he and he's a wonderful friend but
uh but strength theories didn't pan out
it's actually you know
a cue theory uh that had will be
invented in six years from now
according you know with some bright uh
undergraduate here at san diego or there
at heart
right so in other words we would love
nothing better than a wormhole
that connects us to future knowledge so
that we can better life on earth because
that's the ultimate goal of this right
if not to better
earth what else do we have avi i mean we
don't even know there's anything i think
it's our expanding our knowledge of
reality and
you know the the best example is um
bernie madoff yes so bernie madoff had a
beautiful idea
he said give me your money and i'll make
more of it irrespective of what the
stock market does
okay so it was so beautiful that people
gave him the money
i mean what else do you expect i mean if
people are willing to give you money it
means that they really believe your
ideas
right highest accolade yeah yeah so he
was happy
because he got their money they were
happy otherwise they wouldn't give him
the money
the idea was beautiful everyone was
happy
when uh did the idea stop
making sense when the experiment was
done so they asked for the money back
and then the idea didn't pan out and
then he was put in jail so
my point is to figure out which ideas
are ponzi schemes meaning
they do not apply to reality you need
experiments that's the only way to make
progress
yeah you speak to my language yeah so
i can give you an example that we had a
colloquium where a string theory said
well there is some connection between
the landscape of string theory
and inflation and i said great
so now suppose we measure the cosmic
microwave background
and find something different would that
rule out
string theory so that person said
no it will just rule out the conjecture
that i'm making
in connecting string query to the cosmic
macro background string theory is always
right
and so my point is if you don't put skin
in the game
then you don't make progress you have to
make predictions
such that if they are proven wrong you
realize the idea
didn't pan out yeah and that's the way
we expand our knowledge
that's a very fundamental facet of
physics and you can't just say it's a
nuance
if we all agree that this is an exciting
idea we can
dedicate the entire careers
to that subject that is not a viable
argument you want to figure out whether
you are going in there
whether you took the right exit in the
highway
fundamental question and you use this
metaphor panning out and that comes from
gold panning not far from where i am
here in southern california
1849 when the gold rush took place but
people back then would need something
called an assayer
so an assayer and it's actually the
title of galileo's fourth book called
el sagittari and that means this the the
sagittar sagacious one
or the assayer so what is an assailer
avi it's someone who has a worthless
piece of rock
and with that rock you scrape a piece of
something that's supposed to be gold on
it
and if it doesn't leave the right mark
the guy the king
could cut off your head but but
nevertheless the rock is worthless and
yet it has infinite value
because that allows you to test
theories hypotheses conjectures so i've
undertaken in my cur
in my you know role as public outreach
that i do here as the
co-director of the arthur c clarke
center i have taken upon myself what i
call the assayer project
in galileo's footsteps uh you know i'm
one nano galileo but but the point being
i look at string theory i do a pro
string theory video essay i do a
anti-string theory video essay
i have on a guest like you cameron vapha
i have lee small and carlo rivelli
or then i'll have on stephen wolfram and
elijah on one of his chris sabina
haasenfelder and so i'll go through all
these different
uh scenarios because actually that's the
only way if you just have a debate
like have you ever been convinced avi to
vote against the politician that you
supported
ahead of time i've never been convinced
by some debate like i already knew who i
was going to vote by the way this was
the
socratic method the debate and and by
the way you know what happened to
socrates
so he was blamed for um corrupting the
youth
yeah and then was put in jail and
was forced to drink poison that's right
he drank
right and today socrates would have been
cancelled
that's right blame against him was that
he uh
did not believe in the gods of the
athenian people that's right
and so too and now we use his approach
and
it just shows you that how short-sighted
humans are that
at the time when a genius like socrates
proposes
a way of thinking uh that is later
adopted as a very popular way and
at the time he is basically forced to
drink poison
yeah and that's the you know that's the
view that
guides me because you know when i was in
the military at age 18 in israel
uh i served in the paratroopers in the
first three months and
i remember this the statement that
sometimes you need to put your body on
the barbed wire
so that other soldiers will march
forward and
you know if i suffer some pain on social
media
uh it doesn't bother me because the
longer term
goal here has such an impact on humanity
that it's worth it yeah i looked at it
and i thought
i had this conversation also with carlo
and i said imagine back 1864
there's a young guy on twitter his name
is uh his name is james clerk maxwell
and he's got this theory of
electromagnetic waves
for equations that are beautiful he's
very mathematical hard to understand
difficult to comprehend
a few people understand it and uh best
of all avi as you know
he has a beautiful way that mechanically
describes how these waves propagate
through the ether
and they have gears and whirlpools and
eddies and stuff
so imagine this he gets k this is yeah
this is ridiculous he's an
idiot uh cancelled and then for a
hundred years or more
we'd be literally in the dark because we
would have ridiculed and attacked the
man
and i see that happening a lot i see a
lot of criticism uh and carlo kind of
surprised me he's a very much a mensch a
gentleman he said look
string theory or loop quantum gravity
you know who knows what's right
but um but back then they didn't know
what was right and so we were talking
about schroedinger versus
uh heisenberg and and sometimes you only
know as
as saron kirkegaard said you only can
make sense of the past by
by looking back from distance in the
future and i i think of the telescope as
the ultimate
you know what galileo called the
telescope right avi his
the name in the time was the perspective
tube so you get a perspective
on the past by looking back on it and i
feel like we're so quick to judge
folks today and and i i want to respond
to some things because
you're not on social media that's why
you're so productive with 700 papers
and a giant book that i'm hoping we're
going to get to in just
a bit but but you got a lot of prism and
some of it was was just kind of
i mean it seemed it seemed like it was
ad hominem and people were kind of
taking glee in it
and there's an italian expression that
carlo teaches me and it's the higher you
fly the easier you are to shoot down
uh what what part of it um you know
because there's a famous
you know debate that you had with jill
tarter and back in the in the winter
and people were saying like almost
conflating their their their hostility
towards your idea
with with treatment of jill who i love
and as a hero of mine endorsed my book
and
and is really here to millions of of men
and women around the world but like
how is that taken out of context or
what's that relationship like nowadays
of you guys with jill i mean it was not
personal at all and i i really admire
her work over the years and
uh it was fundamentally about my point
that
we can get more funding to the search
for extraterrestrial intelligence and
you know that my latest experience
demonstrates that and i just wanted us
to work together
and that's that was the purpose now uh
of course you know when i'm embedded in
uh so many interviews and i'm exhausted
it might be
interpreted in the wrong way that was
not at all my intention and
um but you know
the idol for me is uh
ed purcell he was a physicist that got
the nobel prize for
the mri and um at some point decided
to look for uh the 21 centimeter line of
hydrogen
uh so he basically put a horn antenna
through
the window of his office and around the
same time there was a visitor from the
group of
jan ort uh and jan ort
that group was looking for the 21
centimeter line of hydrogen from the
milky way galaxy
and they couldn't detect it and then add
percent detected it
so he communicated to that person that
they are not doing it right and he
explained how they should do the
analysis of the data
and how they should collect the data so
they did it and found the same line
and then ed purcell published his paper
discovery paper
which is of fundamental importance to us
astrophysics and cosmology he published
it back to back
with their paper instead of you know
that's unimaginable in today's climate
where people try to compete with each
other and
take credit from each other and
that's you know really the ideal uh
mode of cooperation that i can imagine
in science where you are not really
after your ego that's not the issue
the issue is not speaking about the
individual and trying to
elevate your image so that you can get
awards prices and so forth
it's more about advancing our knowledge
and you know what ed purcell said
we want to detect this line i did it
first but i can explain to my colleagues
how to do it
so then both of us can share the you
know the fun
of reporting about it uh and it was not
about his ego it was not
him demonstrating that he's smarter than
the competitors
and frankly i would find it
hard to believe that nowadays you can
find
someone that behaves that way and if
there are two experiments trying to
detect
the same signal they will try first of
all to do it first
they will not help their oppo
contemporaries in any way and then and
and you know and that's unfortunate
because even in the case of um
of you know okay there are various
interpretations
let's work together let's collect more
data more evidence why should it be so
controversial
why can't we treat it just like dark
matter
where we have multiple possible
interpretations and we have multiple
experiments trying to collect more data
and it's collegial and it's part of the
mainstream
there is nothing controversial about
that and it's a search in the dark
you know so i would much rather live
in that kind of an environment but i
cannot promote
i'm trying to to bring it to fruition by
advocating this
to be a part of the mainstream but i
confront all this resistance and
and you know my hope is it will be
similar to other
frontiers that i promoted in the past
for example i worked on the first stars
the epoch of realization when only a few
people around the world were interested
in it early in my career and now it's
mainstream
uh i worked on imaging black holes and
i wrote first paper together with avery
broderick about imaging
the black hole in m87 which ended up
being imaged
that was the first paper you know
detailing what you might see
[Music]
and you know at the time nobody was
paying too much attention to it
um and i also worked on gravitational
wave astrophysics and
in january 2013 i gave a
an overview on this subject at the
winter school in jerusalem
and another lecturer in that winter
school
stood up and said how dare you waste the
time of these students on this subject
when it will never be important for them
throughout their careers
and then two and a half years later the
ligo experiment detected the first
gravitational wave and now it's the
hottest topic
and these students were still doing
their phd at that time
so my point is simple uh this pattern of
people resisting
and not allowing innovation
has repeated throughout my career on
multiple fronts
but the one thing that is different on
this subject which
i didn't realize in advance is that
people take it emotionally and attack me
personally
and that was not the case uh in the
other subjects or on the first
stage yeah the stakes are lower there it
doesn't as you said before it doesn't
affect your daily
life the way that yeah discovery of an
and other
civilization in the universe would
impact everybody
you know i don't know how long you know
i like to think of avi
you know when i talk with sarah seeger
or i talk to somebody else about sarah
rugheimer recently
and i think about what would happen the
day after we make a discovery and i
think it'd be very different a
biosignature versus a techno signature
a biosignature we kind of already know
what happened and this is part of my
problem
with science popularization by the media
is that
um as had the case with bicep 2 the
story
breaks on front page new york times the
retraction if it ever comes
is b17 of the saturday edition that
nobody reads in other words no
i mean physicists nowadays that say you
you detected inflation and bicep too
that's amazing like they're physicists
let alone my you know my
my godmother or something so the point
i'm trying to make is i i believe that
that these entities should have sort of
a budget for pr
and that budget should be you know to
popularize their discovery but they
should retain a retainer
in reserve for the contingency that
their result may be wrong
and they may have to retract it and
nobody does this i think it should be
part of basic ethics as a scientist our
lawyer friends do it i had on larry
uh you introduced me very uh cordially
to larry tribe
earlier this year and we had a great
conversation and i said you know do you
guys learn ethic
he's like yeah of course it's medical
ethics business how come there's no
scientific ethics no that's part of that
an excellent point
and by the way the progress of science
relies a lot on innovation and
we should create an atmosphere where
young people should be allowed to
deviate from the bitten path
and think outside the box that should be
the culture that we
uh advocate rather than ridicule
anything that deviates and by that we
send a very strong message to young
people
if you want jobs just follow the path
that we laid out and that's a very bad
message
i mean obviously eventually innovation
takes place but it's much slower
and and that's not good um and
i should say that uh you know
my experience is that
you have to stick with with it and pay
attention to
to the ball rather than the audience if
you're going after the truth because
many times in my career
i really uh was swayed by what my
colleagues are saying and
it ended up going in the wrong direction
and
and so it's really important to maintain
independence and the thinking depe you
know critically about what you hear
and uh yeah the last thing i'll say
about that is you know the title of one
of fineman's
my favorite fine book is sure is like
what do you care what other people think
and i think it's a form of kind of uh as
uh people talk about nowadays with alien
civilizations great filter
like you learn a lot about who your real
friends are and who you can trust
and so forth from when you need them not
you know a friend is someone who
you need you know is there for you not
just when the times are good
i want to talk about um moving from that
now to talk about this
wonderful new book which i've learned a
lot from and it's kind of like
dangerous to me obvi because i get so
interested in these things and
i should be you know i should be do uh
doing other things uh
but then reading about you know
calculations of minimum mass uh for a
planet that could host a star
um and you have in here it's so funny
because you have all these guests moya
mcteer who's been a guest on my podcast
sarah sieger who's been a guest of the
pocket um and
i just want to ask you about the genesis
of this book who is it for i mean i can
read it i'm a professional
but um could is it a popular i mean
should people who loved extraterrestrial
pick this up besides you know fattening
the uh bank account which i'm sure that
people make a lot of money from a 750
page text
but no is this for the for the same
audience as extraterrestrial first of
all
uh no so this is a textbook intended for
people that do research on the search
for life
and by the way uh microbial life
uh obviously is no problem for the human
ego
because we can still feel superior so
when perseverance searches for microbes
on mars you know that that's great
everyone endorses embraces that
but if we find you know some piece of
iphone
yeah yeah if we find a an ai system that
outsmarts us obviously people will not
feel so happy about that
and then i think that's a fundamental
difference and um
so and i agree actually sorry i didn't i
didn't get to finish the thought i was
making before just because i interrupted
myself but
but with regard to press conferences so
in 1996 or
five there was a press conference for
the discovery of microbial life
evidence on mars found from antarctic
rocks
that were collected by a project in the
allen lands hills
and to this day it's not resolved what
those are but i think it's noteworthy
that
let's say 50 percent of the people that
heard that press conference from bill
clinton
on the frontline of the white house that
was shown in the movie contact
with uh by by uh carl sagan and vasquez
andrew ian
on the into the impossible podcast but
um they they probably still think that
that was discovered in other words it
was never retracted
so i think it's kind of our obligation
though as scientists we should have some
kind of budget to retract even for
microbial
i mean there's a lot of people who
believe that is still a valid scientific
discovery
right that's definitely the case so this
textbook that
is called life in the cosmos that is
uh over 800 pages long uh was written by
me and and my postdoc my former postdoc
manasvillingam
and the intention was to include both
the search for microbial life primitive
life
and the search for intelligent life in
one book
and there was such a book much shorter
than this one
written by shklovsky and sagan yeah
and that was in the mid 1960s and
um since then there was no such book
and we decided that it's time to update
um
our knowledge uh and summarize it
in a way that would serve the community
of researchers
working on this both on the search for
microbial life which is much more
mainstream
and the search for technological
signatures
and let me give you an example it it's
often thought that
you know that if you build instruments
for uh
searching for microbial life they cannot
really be used for the other purpose but
here is an example suppose you build
those
very expensive telescopes that the
astronomy community
is now contemplating that would aim to
find traces of the fingerprints of
oxygen
and methane in the atmospheres of
habitable planets around other stars and
the
the first thing to to realize is that
oxygen
uh was not very abundant on earth
in the first two billion years so for
half of the age of
of the earth uh there wasn't much oxygen
even though there was a lot of microbial
life
so if you don't find oxygen it doesn't
tell you that there is
no microbial life and the second point
to make is
oxygen could be produced by chemical
processes
that have nothing to do with life so so
it's actually
you know even though you might need to
invest billions of dollars
to build those telescopes it will not
give you a definitive answer but
if you find cfcs those very complex
molecules produced by
coolants or industries here on earth
that by the way destroy the ozone layer
um
if you found those on on an exoplanet
then that would
imply industrial life and you can search
for those
using the same spectrographs that you're
using to search for
oxygen so right my point is simple that
you know to motivate those expensive
telescopes
why not contemplate also the search for
technological signatures and
they should be as mainstream as
biological signatures and and speaking
about seti that you mentioned before the
search was mainly for radio signals
uh but that's just like trying to have a
fun conversation and for that you need a
counterpart to be alive
at the time that you're having the
conversation that's right and if most of
the civilizations are dead by now if
they
originated around stars that predated us
by billions of years because most stars
formed billions of years before the sun
then the chance of meeting another
civilization at the same technological
phase that we are going through is very
small so most of the time you will hear
silence but if on the other hand you are
doing archaeology
then you can find objects that were left
behind
by civilizations that existed in the
past and
it's just like um plastic bottles on the
ocean that keep accumulating
all the time and and you can look for
them uh even if
the sender is not around anymore and
then that's what they
i think makes more sense to do space
archaeology and that's what we are
trying to do with the the galileo
project
one one paper uh you know i'm always
like i wish i could get avi to spend
more of his time on the cmb
but there's got to there's no connection
between the cmb
and the origin of life nope i was wrong
avi loeb
uh 2013 solo paper
the habitable epoch of the early
universe do you remember this paper came
out right after bicep two uh v do you
remember it
and in it you say something fascinating
that one of my
former colleagues and dear friends mayor
shimon tel aviv university pointed out
to me said
thermal gradients are needed for life
this is in your paper these can be
supplied by geological variations on the
surface of rocky planets
and you talk you talk about sources of
free energy
and so forth but you say these internal
heat sources
in addition to that heating by a nearby
star may have kept the planets warm
without the cmb
but you could say that the cmba at late
times at earlier times rather would have
been warmer and that would have allowed
maybe liquid water on an otherwise cold
planet
uh have you updated that is that paper
you know is there any
sort of uh you know follow-on to that
like the interplay between the cosmos
and the microcosmos of microorganisms
yeah so
um the thing that i realized the one day
in the shower
i usually get my ideas there is that uh
you know the universe is cooling as it
expands and if you go back in time it
was hotter we know that
but then i i thought to myself actually
if you go back when the universe
was smaller by a factor of a hundred
then
you get to room temperature uh yeah the
temperature now is roughly three degrees
and
back then it was 300 which is room
temperature
and if there were any planets then then
you might have liquid water on the
surface irrespective whether they're
close to a star that warms them up
so the habitable region would actually
be the entire universe
at that time now the only limitation is
whether there are planets at those early
times it's 15 million years after the
big bang
turns out that my own work demonstrated
that
the first stars formed later about 50
million years later
and so if you um assume the standard
cosmological model
the way we uh have now
uh then you would never get any planets
made
15 million years after the big bang and
that's
unfortunate because life would have been
quite interesting back then
you would basically be immersed in a
bath
of radiation left over from the big bang
that keeps you warm
and you won't have seasons uh it will
just be warm or you can
sit on the beach and enjoy yourself
exactly and who wouldn't like to do that
of course we can do that almost any day
of the year here avi
in sunny san diego wish you were here
for one of these book launches your next
you know book
i'm sure you're writing many more uh
wonderful things to come but i just want
to close with kind of the big picture
i want to take you back uh to you know
the the
the late summer of 1609 in
northern italy with galileo galilei you
have a
moment now to talk to him and say
whatever you want to say to him what
would you tell the maestro what would
you talk about
what would you be most fascinated by to
exchange with him scientists to
scientists father the father human to
human
what would you most like to talk to him
about if you could well i would
try to get his lessons of life so to
speak from the experience that he went
through because
apparently we haven't learned those
lessons and we
are repeating the same mistakes that
were made around galileo at the time and
the question is why because humans you
know you might say there are they have
some intelligence right so they should
learn from experience
and the way i i see it is because
there are some forces psychological
forces that drive us
away from the right behavior and
those are you know feeling hurt
when we learn something that doesn't
quite line up with what we expected
we have a problem with that we feel that
we are
it's taking us out of our comfort zone
because we know something
and now there is something that looks
anomalous completely different
and we just don't want to go there and
you know the question is how to get
people uh
to cooperate when a revolution takes
place and that's pretty much what
galileo went through
and i believe that if we allow data to
come
in and now i can thank the very generous
donors that gave me that money that
enables this if we allow data to come in
we will discover something new
okay so the self-fulfilling prophecy is
if you don't search you will never find
and
on the other hand if we do search we
will find something
and i believe that within my lifetime
there is a chance
that we will get our hands on a
technological relic from another
civilization
and that would be amazing so i have
something to
wait for not the response of my
colleagues
not uh flattery from people around me
um rather allowing nature to give me
uh new knowledge by looking at it
and that's all and i don't need anything
more than that
that's beautiful avi i want to close
with the words of galileo
and he was an amazing human being
amazing writer he said i do not presume
to be able to address all the proper and
sufficient causes of those effects
which are new to me and which
consequently i have had no chance to
think about
what i am about to say i propose merely
as a key
to open portals to a road never before
trodden by
anyone in a firm hope that minds
more acute than mine will broaden this
road
and penetrate further along it than i
have done in my first revealing of it
and maybe avi maybe you're in that
tradition your students the millions of
people that you
inspire around the world maybe you are
that future person
are your teammates and your and your and
your students and the people that you
call colleagues
maybe you're those people that will
unlock the key you have the key to
unlock the portal galileo talked about
i want to wish you hudsola much success
and congratulations avi it's a wonderful
thing and it's a delight that i was able
to
break the news on the into the
impossible podcast after your press
conference today
thank you so much for having me i had
great fun
[Music]
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
you